- YouTube, what's up?
So, so grateful that you
clicked and you're about
to watch a new YouTube video.
But before you do,
212-931-5731, that is my
texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one on
one engagement in there.
And also access opportunity first looks
in that environment.
212-931-5731, join it now.
And now, to the video you've
been wanting to watch.
If you asked me, "Give
me a top ten great idea
to start a business right now."
One of them is to start a--
- [Voiceover] You got your perspective.
(engine roaring)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(R&B music)
- Hey everybody.
Welcome to a conversation on the podcast.
A format that it seems a
lot of people are liking
and so we're gonna continue to do it.
I'm super excited about this interview,
because this is a great story
about if you don't ask, you don't get.
So, I'm gonna let this
lovely lady introduce herself
and tell you who she is.
Then I'll tell you how she got here.
And then we're gonna shoot the shit.
(Heather laughing)
- What's up?
I'm so excited
Good to see you again.
- to be back here.
- Thank you.
- It's crazy.
So, I'm Heather Monahan.
I was formally a chief revenue officer
in corporate America, for 14 years.
I got fired two years ago.
And when that happened, I wrote
and self published my first
book, Confidence Creator,
which trumped Trump for number one
in business biographies on Amazon.
Have the screenshot to prove that one.
And I've just been out now speaking.
I just did my first Ted
Talk Saturday, thank you.
And, um, I'm just tearing it up.
- So, so, I was on your podcast.
- Thank you for that by the way.
- You're welcome for that, a
couple months ago, Heather.
And then uh, thank you bro.
And then at the end or
in it or towards the end,
you're like, "Can I be on yours?"
And I said, "Yep, you can."
And the, and one, we had a great,
I thought it was a great session
on your podcast.
- Everyone loved it!
- Yeah.
- It was good.
- Let's jump into that.
How was the feedback?
- Amazing, I mean--
- [Gary] What was the
thing that stood out?
- People said that it was
a different version of you,
because we talked a lot about family.
Remember when we talked about
- [Gary] Yep, we did, I did.
- your grandmother?
- [Gary] Yep.
- Like we really got
into some different topics,
I think that typically
people don't explore with you
which was cool.
- Cool.
And so, great energy.
To your point, I did think it was,
it got into a lot of
territories that were different.
And yeah, I just, you know what's funny?
I, and for everybody
listening, you've seen Zane,
who's sitting here, ask me
in a Q&A, "Can I get a job?"
I say, "Yes."
He literally works here.
You've seen other things I say yes to.
And then I say no all the time.
Like, thousands and
thousands, not thousands,
hundreds and hundreds
of people have asked me
in those kind of scenarios,
"Can I be on the podcast?"
Or this or that.
"Can I get a shout on your social?"
Things of that nature.
And I always feel super
comfortable saying no or yes.
But to the point, and
something that I'd like
to start talking about as a kick off point
before we go into a
little more context on you
and then anything else
you want to talk about is,
how much, how often do you ask
for what you're looking for?
How has that worked
for you in your career?
When did you develop it?
Has it always been there?
I think, I put out a
piece of content recently
where I told everybody to
DM every, to text, everybody
in their address book if they knew anybody
that could give them business, right?
So if you're selling,
for everybody listening,
if you missed it.
If you sell teachers,
if you have an agency,
if you have a product, a book, instead
of texting everybody in your phone,
and I'm talking like
starting with Aaron Andleson
and ending with Zack Zarlington.
If you text everybody instead of saying,
"Hey, can you buy my book?"
You could say, "Hey, I
have a new book, Aaron,
do you know anybody who'd
be interested in it?"
Which of course, eludes to maybe them
or maybe they actually do
recommend somebody on it.
That really struck a cord
and I've gotten hundreds
of emails in the last three
weeks of people that did it
and had miraculous results.
Like literally my landscaping business was
about to go under.
I was going to put
everything on a credit card,
but I saw that clip, texted 483 people
and have 13 new clients
and don't need to take out credit cards.
So, so much of why we're sitting here is
you just had the audacity,
the strategy, the balls,
the thoughtfulness, whatever one wants
to put in front of it, to actually ask.
Which is something people
are super fearful of.
How are you with that?
Obviously, you did it with me.
Has that always been there?
Has that not been there?
Tell me about you with the
relationship of asking.
That is my opening question.
- So you're gonna crack up.
This is funny.
So you know Zack that runs
your speaker business?
- [Gary] Zack Nadler, yes I do.
- Okay, so I--
- [Gary] Vaynerspeakers.com.
- So I was on a conference call with Zack,
and I don't know Zack.
And I was gonna be
interviewing Jesse Itzler
and Sara Blakely a month ago in Boston.
They had this call with
me to basically strategize
how it would go and whatnot.
So I said, "Listen,
Zack, I don't know you,
"but here's the thing.
"I wanna come out to Biggie
Small Mo Money Mo Problem,
"me and Jesse will go
like, riff this thing up
"and start rapping."
He's like, "Excuse me.
"Uh, no.
"We do it traditional."
But, if you don't think out of the box
and then just bring it.
Like, whatever crazy heat you have,
you're gonna get nothing.
I wanted to be memorable.
I want people to say, "Holy cow!"
Did I get what I want?
No.
- [Gary] Which is fine.
- He didn't let me do it.
Which is fine.
But he will remember me forever.
'Cause as soon as he saw me at Hyperbroke,
he was like, "Oh my God,
you're that crazy lady
"that wanted to come
out with Jesse rapping."
- [Gary] Yes.
- So even if you don't
get what you're going for,
you're gonna be remembered forever.
- Are you better at asking
for things in business,
or in person life, or both?
- Business, no.
- [Gary] Me too.
- I'm not good in personal life.
- [Gary] Me neither.
- I'm not good.
I have so much less
fear of "no" in business
than I did growing up with girls.
Like, so much more.
I used to laugh thinking like,
- [Heather] Totally.
- "Why am I 13 and
willing to actual business
with 43 year olds, but I'm scared
to ask Stacy Johnson to the dance?"
- It's, I'm the same thing.
- And by the way, what's
ironic about that is,
I actually have seen far
more people the other way.
I always use to think
it was one in the same.
And it was really funny
to me to see guys or gals
that were good social
life wise asking crippled
by cold calling or cold
emailing or asking.
Which is why I asked you that.
I've come to realize wow, for some reason,
there's some sort of
difference in those two worlds.
And I'm curious about who
stinks at both, who's great
at both, and then who's
good at one or the other
and which one.
- I wish I good in my personal life, no.
- What was your, what was the
most business-y thing you did
when you grew up?
- [Heather] Being a kid?
- Yeah.
Were you in business at all--
- Oh yeah, I had a paper
I was, I grew up poor.
My mom was a single mother.
- [Gary] Where'd you grow up?
- Worcester, Mass.
- [Gary] Oh yes.
- The 508, remember that's what Troudy
and I had that in common.
- [Gary] Yes, yes, yes, I remember.
I had a paper route since
I was nine, I worked in
fast food restaurants,
I was busboy at diners.
I just always worked.
- And so, what about
entrepreneurship verus job.
Obviously you were CRO, now you got fired,
you're doing your own thing.
- [Heather] Yeah it's crazy.
- A lot of people that
grow up with adversity,
single mom, having to
work, love the stability
of a real serious job.
- Yes.
- [Gary] You went that route.
- I loved that.
I never thought about
being an entrepreneur.
That was a crazy idea.
- Can you tell the kids that are listening
that neither one of us are under 25 so...
- [Heather] 45.
- Right.
Like, how much we didn't grow
up with entrepreneurship being an option?
- No.
You're the poster boy for
the entrepreneurial world.
But that didn't exist when we were kids.
Everyone was in corporate America.
I didn't even know there was such a thing.
That wasn't something
somebody talked about.
- The only way you heard it was like,
oh they own their own business.
You would not even use
the word entrepreneur.
- [Heather] No.
- And as a matter of fact,
the word entrepreneur,
the few times I did hear it,
usually meant rich kid who does nothing
and parents are paying for it.
(Heather laughing)
Really.
It's really interesting.
That's how I recall it.
Like four or five guys,
that I can think of,
growing up at 16, 22, 21,
they would have a card
that was like I'm an entrepreneur.
And was like, "What does that mean?"
And basically then somebody
else, when they would leave,
be like, "Oh, they just live on the beach.
"There parents are--"
- Do you remember the,
PHD, papa has dealership?
- [Gary] Yes!
- Yeah.
That was the entrepreneur back in the day.
- What do you most
thinking about these days?
What is your business today?
- Well, right now, my
number one revenue stream
is the speaking business.
Which is insane.
I can't believe how much money I get paid.
- [Gary] I agree.
- It's crazy!
So exciting, I wish I
had known about this.
- How many times did you
speak for free, if ever?
- I just spoke free at
the freaking Ted Talk!
- [Gary] No, no that I know.
- That's a whole
other situation.
- I'm talking about prior to getting paid.
Or was your first--
- My whole career!
For 20 years in corporate
America, I was a sales leader.
Everyday I spoke.
You're speaking to your
time, clients, whatever.
- But how about after you got fired?
Actually, tell that quick story
before we run out of time.
- [Heather] Which one?
- The framework of what
I recall from our podcast
and really where you go?
You have this big gig, you got fired,
you had to make an adjustment.
- Yeah, no, that was the scariest thing.
Because I wasn't comfortable
with that unknown space
like how you are.
You've always been in this lane.
- [Gary] Yeah, that's my world.
- For me, that was never my world.
I like that safe, I was tricking myself.
I thought I was really safe
being in corporate America
which is bullshit.
Because any company can be sold tomorrow.
And you only have your brand
- [Gary] Correct.
- and you, and your
experiences, and your network.
So you are not safe unless
you are actually doing it.
I feel so much safer now
that I work for myself.
- [Gary] 'Cause you're in control.
- I'm in control.
I trust my boss.
You know, I'm not gonna sell the company.
I'm good.
It's a seismic shift to
think about how I believe--
- What's the first thing you thought?
How did you get fired, in person?
- Yeah, in a two minute meeting.
In two minutes.
- [Gary] With HR?
- No, with the new CEO.
The CEO I had worked for
for 14 years became ill.
He elevated his daughter to replace him.
And she immediately said,
"Come over, I need to
have a meeting with you."
And she basically passed
two memos in front of me
and said, "I don't need a
chief revenue officer anymore.
"I don't need you, which
memo would you like to sign?"
And one said Heather Monohan's been fired
and the other one said Heather
Monohan, wonderful employee,
blah, blah, blah.
But I knew, this wasn't my first rodeo.
I knew that there was--
- Did you have any
relationship with her, prior?
- Well she was the CFO.
- [Gary] Got it, got it.
- And I was the CRO.
So we were like, she
wanted to cut everything
and I wanted to spend everything.
- I got it, of course, that makes sense.
- [Heather] But I never--
- Did you know when she called you over
that it was kaputskies or did you hope--
- No, 'cause she's a smart woman.
She's very analytical, she's a CFO.
She's the antithesis of me.
But I thought she knew,
Heather's good at her job.
- [Gary] The yin and the yang.
- I'm not gonna fire her.
I figured she was gonna rough
me up a little to intimidate.
- Or try to get aligned.
- [Heather] Well I didn't
think that was gonna happen.
- So, were you shocked?
- I was, I cried the whole
three hour ride home.
- Do you have it in you in
that scenario, what's funny
about me, is every time anything happens,
I start the process of
worst case scenario.
Dustin emails me and says, "I
need three minutes with you."
The first, this is real, it just happened.
The first thing I think
is, I hope he's not sick.
I go so funny.
- [Heather] Oh my gosh.
- I go into what's the
worst that could happen?
I hope he's not sick.
I hope something weird didn't happen,
like John did something weird to him
and it needs to go to
HR, that's the next--
(Heather laughing)
To me, it's in this order, something,
that person, or their family is sick.
Next, something super
politically incorrect, legal,
sexual harassment, that's
the next worst thing.
Third is, a good employee wants to leave.
So if like a good employee
says, "I need to see you,"
that's the third thing I think.
But that's all I think.
I don't think like,
"Oh, it's gonna be a
five minute check in."
This is, by the way,
everyone who's listening,
this is the shit of owning your shit.
This is actually the way you think.
This is why it's interesting what you,
like it's crazy to me, but
it makes so much sense.
Which is why I'm jumping on this point,
I never really thought about this.
The only thing I would've
thought when she wanted
to see me is, "I'm getting fired."
But what I just realized
based on your reaction,
literally it just hit me, is like, right,
when you're completely
accountable to yourself,
which is what you're figuring you now,
all the greatness of loving
your boss and feeling safe?
- [Heather] Yeah.
- The shit part is, the way
my brain actually works.
Listen to what I'm telling you.
Every time anyone reaches
out to me, in order,
I think about, terminal illness
for them or their loved one,
sexual harassment or stealing
or something horrible,
third is they're leaving
and we value them.
That is literally the
order that my head goes.
Then it's like, "Hey, Gary,
can we get five hundred bucks
for a T.G.I. Friday's party
next Thursday for the team?"
I'm like, "Yes!"
(Heather laughing)
That's why I'm always in a
good mood when it's anything
but three, and the third
one's not even that scary,
'cause genuinely, on the
record, for anybody from Vayner
that hears this, if one
feels like they're ready
to move on, I wanna help them.
It's the first two that
scare the fuck out of me
and always what I think.
Every time a client reaches
out, we're getting fired.
Never we're getting
more growth of business.
Macro, I'm optimistic.
Macro, I'm like, we're
gonna win, we're the best.
Micro...
Micro, I'm not.
- That means something big.
I don't know what it is,
I'm not a psychologist,
but it's gotta be something.
- Let me tell you what
it means in your world.
When you're walking in there, micro,
she's abut to fucking fire me.
Macro, I'm fucking a capable human being,
I'm gonna fucking figure it out.
Whether I'm gonna get another fucking job
that's gonna pay me more,
or I'm gonna start my own career
and fucking speak at TedX.
Got it?
- Yeah, but I was the opposite of that.
- I understand.
- [Heather] That's crazy.
- Which is what I'm thinking,
why I'm saying this so aggressively is
'cause there's two people
listening right now,
in this show, in the
framework of business,
entrepreneurs and employees.
And it's like an interesting
debate for people that are,
like, for example, there's a lot of people
that are employees right
now that are thinking
about making the jump where
they listen to what I just said,
and are saying, "Do I wanna
live a life where I have
"to always be that on and
anxious at all times?"
'Cause yes, I am a firefighter.
Like, what's amazing
about your life right now
is you're in control.
What's terrible is you're in control.
- [Heather] Right.
- Like, if you decide
to chill this morning,
like if Dustin, I'm just looking at him.
If Dustin's just not feeling it today,
and I'm pumped all the time
and have days when you wake up,
and you're just not fully feeling it,
one could argue that
you can call out sick.
You can lollygag your day.
- [Heather] You can.
- For me, that's, I'm like, "Oh,
"the reason I haven't had
a sick day in nine years is
"that's more scary than the lollygagging."
Obviously if I run a 105 fever,
I'm willing to stay home.
But all those days, I mean,
I called out of school
13 to 23 times a year.
I made pretend I was sick 13 times a year.
Once I figured out in high
school that the nurse had
to send you home if you
weren't willing to go back
to class, legally, it was over.
I just laid there until they sent me home.
(Heather chuckling)
I'm like, "I'm nauseous, I'm
unconscious, I feel weird,
I'm anxious, get me out of here."
And then the best part was I'd go outside,
my mom would have to pick me
up freshman and sophomore year,
and junior year before I got my car,
and literally I would never look at her.
Because the second I
would look into her eyes,
I would start laughing,
because we both knew the gig.
- The gig was up.
- [Gary] Anyway not tattle.
What happens, you cry all
the way home and then what?
- I went under a weighted
blanket, grabbed a bottle
of chardonnay.
And then I did something--
- [Gary] How was the chardonnay?
- It wasn't Empathy.
It needed to be Empathy.
- [Gary] I know that.
- Now it's Empathy!
- [Gary] No, but how was it?
- Oh, it was good.
- [Gary] Good, okay.
- All right, so here's the thing though.
I did something super smart,
and I had never done it.
I posted on social media
that I just got fired.
I just was vulnerable and I just said,
"I need your help."
- [Gary] You needed something.
- I needed help.
I didn't know what to do.
And it was crazy, Froggy
from the Elvis Duran show,
tweeted at me, "I wanna help you,
"is there anyway I can help you?"
And I tweeted back,
"Yeah, book me on Elvis."
He booked me right away
to go on the Elvis Show.
I went on the show and
halfway through the interview,
Elvis says, "Well obviously
you're writing a book."
And I said, "Well obviously!"
But I wasn't.
So I googled on the plan, on the way home,
- [Gary] How to write a--
- "How do you write a book?"
And it says, just write.
So I was like, "I can do that."
So I just went home and I
started writing and writing.
And then, you know, it
took like two months
and I was done with my book.
- Did you debate self-publishing?
'Cause I heard you earlier say that,
versus getting a book deal?
Was the book deal too long and drawn out
and you wanted to get it out?
- Speed to market.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Obviously, with my
history in business, I knew,
speed to market is critical.
And I've gotta move fast and
I'm gonna move so much faster
than some traditional publishing house.
I'm glad that I self-published.
- [Gary] Did you consider getting a job?
- Like, going back?
- [Gary] To a job, yes.
Not to the company.
- So I had to sign,
I had to sign a noncompete
when I took the chief
revenue officer position.
So for one year, I
couldn't go back to media.
So I thought to myself,
If I'm gonna start over
as a rookie somewhere, why
wouldn't I roll the dice
on me versus, if I'm
gonna go do something new,
I'll just work for me.
- [Gary] So what happened next
you write the book.
- So I write the book and then I google,
"How do you promote a book?"
And you speak to promote a book.
So I was like, "Oh, that's easy.
"I already know how to speak."
I didn't know there was
a speaking business.
I had no idea.
- [Gary] Me neither before I got into it.
- It's so crazy to me.
I always think how many other
things do we not know about
that we could be great at?
- [Gary] An uncomfortable amount.
- So that's what's so exciting about--
- I mean that's my entire thesis.
There was some gal in line
in this speech I gave.
And she's like, "Gary, I
know thesis of taste things
"in your 20s and figure out what you love
"or what you're great at
or what to your point."
And she's like, "But I've done all that.
"What do I do?"
And I looked at her, she
was from Belarus too.
So I was like, you know, kind
of like, from the homeland.
And I'm like, "Let me get this straight,
you've decided that you've
done everything on Earth,
and you now know every."
Like, it was just funny
to watch her realize,
"Oh I've only done nine things.
"And there's nine billion things."
There's so many things!
- Well it's like, I was just
mentioning to Marcia Kilgore
how she's disrupted the beauty business.
Look at that.
This is someone who has
been in the beauty business
for a couple of decades
and one day just said,
"Hey, I'm gonna flip this
whole model upside down."
Now it just challenges me to think
how can I flip everything upside down?
- Everything is in plight
'cause the internet.
Bookstores and limos
are just the first ones.
Everything.
Every single thing is vulnerable.
- [Heather] Everything.
- Everything.
What do you wanna,
everybody who is listening,
you like eyelash extensions?
Vulnerable.
You like ice cream?
You like kindergarten?
Vulnerable.
Literally, this is why
people sometimes struggle
to understand what I'm saying.
All of it.
The answer's yes.
There's nothing that is protected.
Amazon's vulnerable.
I'm telling you right now,
let me explain what I mean by that.
If you ask me, give me
a top ten great idea
to start a business right now,
one of them is to start a local bookstore.
- [Heather] That's shocking.
- That's why I'm making a point of it.
I believe that we are at enough scale
of books being delivered by Amazon
that the countermove is now up for debate.
That if you build a
trendy, coffee, we work-y,
coworking kind of vibe-y
drive bar, sephora, rad,
fucking bookstore, that people will go.
That if you make it experiential
and have another variable
that people will pay the extra dollars
that are more than Amazon to be there.
- [Heather] I don't know.
So I had the Ted Talk.
I ordered like seven dresses online.
'Cause when you're a woman,
you have to really think
about what you're gonna wear
for something like this.
- [Gary] What about men?
- No, it's not as big a deal for man.
- [Gary] Why not?
- It's not.
You're not gonna be scrutinized
the way that I would be.
- [Gary] I think it's time
that we start having
counter debates of where we,
some men are wildly focused
on what they're wearing.
They're not gonna be scrutinized though,
that's irrelevant.
- [Gary] Oh, scrutinized.
- Yeah, everyone's gonna
talk about what I wore.
Like, "It's too sexy."
Or, "She's not feminine."
Or whatever.
- [Gary] By why does
that matter?
- I don't know it matters
in a woman's head.
These are the things
that women think about.
- Men think about how
much money they make,
how tall they are.
Men think about a lot of things too.
I'm not making a men women thing.
I'm making it a how do you eliminate that?
Because then you go fast?
- I'll move out of Miami,
that's what I should do
to eliminate that.
- [Gary] Or just not value
people's opinions pro or con.
- You're right.
You are right.
But that--
- [Gary] I want that for you.
'Cause I want that for everybody.
- I want that from you too.
- [Gary] I want it for every,
I went to the Knicks game
last night and 400,000,
my friend said to me,
"Holy Fuck you're more
popular than every Knick."
And when I tell you that
I can't even feel it,
I can't.
Which is why I can
handle the next morning,
when somebody wrote a blog
post to say that I'm trying
to exploit the sports card industry
'cause Topps paid me
$25,000 to curate a set.
(Heather laughing)
You need to be able to, I
really want this for you.
And I have a lot of empathy when you talk
about women's appearance.
The enormity of DMs I
get from women that say,
"Look, easy for you, I spend
40 years before I go on film."
And I'm like, look, there's so
many, like I understand that.
Historical truths, men
and women are different.
There's a million things
that go into that.
But there are so many men
that are shy to go on camera
because of their looks.
And there are so many women that are not.
And vice versa.
- [Heather] Sure.
- And I'm just trying to
get everybody into a mindset
of happiness, which is actually truth
of elimination of judgment.
But nonetheless, you might also enjoy it.
It just might be fun
for you subconsciously
to go through seven dress.
- [Heather] No!
- Maybe not.
- [Heather] Absolutely not!
- No, that's pure hell.
- [Gary] Understood.
- But the whole point,
this is not why I was telling you this.
- [Gary] Yeah, what were you telling me?
- So the whole point is this.
So I had to order all these dresses
'cause I wanted to get the right outfit
and drive myself crazy.
But then, I'd gotten
these dresses from Sacs
and I look at, I usually
order from Revolve,
which is a customer
- [Gary] I know it.
- centered business right?
So it's easy to do business
with them, return stuff.
- [Gary] Also, great pricing right?
- Great pricing, great product.
Hashtag not an ad.
Well, all of a sudden, I look at Sacs.
You have to pay if you wanna
return it via UPS or whatever.
So I'm like, I'm not gonna do that.
I'll bring it into the store
'cause that's just principle, it's wrong.
So I bring it into the store,
I hadn't been in the store in a long time.
The guy literally is like,
"Listen, here's my card."
The guy that works at the desk.
There's no one in the store.
And he said, "Here's my card.
"Next time you order online,
"if you can just include this code,
"now I'll get a commission."
And I thought to myself, "This
model is so freaking broken."
That this poor sales guy
is begging for someone
to use their code so that
they can make a dollar off
of something they used to
have people come in the store,
and that model's just broken.
- [Gary] Yeah, that sucked.
That whole experience that you just--
- Horrible!
- [Gary] I would never go to Sacs again
if somebody asked me that.
- Horrible experience.
- [Gary] And I'm not mad at Sacs,
I'm just mad at the whole thing.
- I feel bad for the guy.
Well obviously, it's not,
they're not training their,
I mean there's just so many issue there.
The customer's not the
focus, it's all broken.
- Yeah.
Before we head out, 'cause
we don't have that much time.
What is, what's on your mind?
What do you wanna to share with audience?
What are you talking about these days?
- Oh my gosh.
Stepping into fear.
Because I was paralyzed
by fear for so long.
I knew that lady didn't like
me when I was working there.
But I would just ignore it all the time.
And that chipped away at me.
- [Gary] Sure.
- My confidence.
It chipped away at my potential.
And when you erode
yourself in a situation.
At some point, you have to
look in the mirror and say,
"Enough is enough."
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I've gotta just go out
there and take a chance on me.
And I wasn't able to do
that, I got pushed out.
But I'm so glad now that I did.
And this Ted Talk that I did,
it's so ridiculous standing
on a little red circle and
having a ticker going off
for ten minutes.
It was one of the most
stressful things I've done.
But once you're done with it, it's like,
I said to myself right when
I was walking out there,
maybe I'm gonna bomb
right now, I don't know.
'Cause this is not like
anything I've ever done.
But I said, I'm gonna love me so much more
when I get off the stage
'cause I walked out there.
- Sure.
And so, what since the
fear professionally,
have you stepped into?
- Oh my gosh, everything.
- [Gary] Give me--
- I left my fiance
that I'd been in a relationship
with for eight years.
- [Gary] That's a massive one.
- That was like massive.
Yeah, it's like a domino effect for sure,
of different things that have occurred.
And I keep pushing myself
to try different things
and go to that--
- Talk to me about your,
so speaking is a core thing for you?
- [Heather] Yeah, that's
my number one thing.
- So let's talk about
personal brand building,
which would lead to more speaking gigs.
- [Heather] Yeah.
- What are you doing content wise?
How are you thinking about?
What are--
- I'm not doing a good job of that.
I need a D Rock in my life.
I mean that's definitely
the next investment
that I have to make.
- [Gary] The D Rock part
is not the punchline.
It's the strategy that makes
you comfortable with it.
- But you could--
- [Gary] You could've a D Rock--
- You can have a great
- [Gary] You could've had a--
- strategy, but if you don't
have the team to execute it.
- [Gary] You could have a team.
- Well, it's, where do you
wanna make your investment?
That's what you have to--
- [Gary] That I respect.
- You need to--
- [Gary] So you're saying
it's a financial issue?
- A hundred percent.
Because that's the difference now--
- Let me ask you a question.
- Do you believe if you
tweeted much like you tweeted,
"I got fired," that, "I'm
looking for an intern,
"for a very low cost.
"But you'll get the skillset
to do the D Rock thing."
"And can you afford it.
"Whether you're A, super hungry
"and you think it's strategically right
"because you get close to me.
"Or B, you just come from
highly wealthy parents
"who are gonna subsidize
your life during this time
"and you want the experience."
Do you feel like you
could get that person?
- You're right.
That's a good point.
- [Gary] Okay, so that's that.
Let's put that on a shelf.
What else are you doing on content?
Where are you on LinkedIn?
- Oh I kill on LinkedIn.
- [Gary] Tell me.
- Well--
- [Gary] How often do you
post, what do you post,
how are you thinking about it?
- You know what, I don't strategize, but--
- [Gary] And tell me the truth
because I really wanna help you
in these final minutes.
- Oh my god, that's so.
Thank you.
That's so sweet of you.
- [Gary] How often do you post
on LinkedIn?
Tell the truth.
- Once a day.
- [Gary] Once a day.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Written?
- Well, I do videos.
But then, my viral posts,
like I've had millions
of views on my posts.
It's always nine professional
pictures of like,
that's the recipe for whatever reason.
And sharing something vulnerable,
those ones go viral, for me.
- Have you tried to use
LinkedIn like Twitter?
I've been thinking about this a lot.
I've been thinking about the notion
of LinkedIn's algorithm is
highly organic right now.
And one or two sentences of
thoughtful business chatter.
Three or four sentences on the fly,
like you're going down the
elevator now after this podcast.
And we talked about something
that you thought about.
Be like, literally here's,
literally the LinkedIn post,
"Just did a podcast, made me really think
"about the things I continue to say no to
"that are actually yeses,
"I just need to look at them
from a different angle."
This is what I always
challenge myself for.
'Cause it's, I think, what I'm good at,
in giving advice for.
That as a LinkedIn post,
would take you 39 seconds.
I think you should be posting
based on what you're trying
to achieve in your career eight
to 15 times today on LinkedIn.
- Get out of here!
- [Gary] Yep.
- And that's not gonna be
overkill you don't think?
- [Gary] No.
- It's not spamming people?
- No, because people
aren't gonna see it all.
- [Heather] Right.
- What people don't
understand is the algorithm,
the thing that people haven't figured out,
is the algorithm is on
the side of the person
that's consuming it, not
on the side of the person
that's making it.
- [Heather] Interesting.
That's a good point.
- And so, the algorithm is gonna show,
you know who it's gonna overkill?
The 49 people on Earth
that think you're the
greatest thing of all time
and they're gonna see all 15--
- [Heather] 'Cause they'll
be fine with it, that's fine.
- They're gonna be pumped!
I'd like to get 49 pieces of content
from Randy the Macho Man Savage
in 1988 everyday of my life.
So, no.
That's why the algorithms work.
People blame the algorithms,
like, "Fuck you!"
I'm like mmh-mmh, the
algorithm's there for the people.
It's consumer-centric.
The reason the algorithms work is 'cause
that they're consumer-centric.
If you think I'm rad, you're gonna see me?
'Cause you're gonna slow down
when you're consuming it.
You're gonna consume, you're gonna like,
you're gonna comment.
And that's an indicator
that you're gonna see it.
- [Heather] Do you respond to haters
when they post on your--
- Yeah.
- [Heather] You do?
- Not always.
I mean, right now, the sheer
volume, between text messages,
social, email, that I'm
getting is unsustainable.
Even if I did it for 18 hours a day.
But I'm very, I had 30
minute coffee this morning
with a gentleman who, I
wouldn't call him a hater,
but was aggressively pushing back
against me on social.
And we had a lovely
conversation about marketing
and how we see it differently.
I get a lot of value, I mean, look.
There's people that are making up stuff.
The kid that wrote the
article today about me
in the sports card world, made up stuff.
'Cause I posted a photo of
a box of cards yesterday,
which I did for my friend
that runs StockX, Josh,
as a friendly gesture.
He's turned it into this
highly hidden compensate,
I mean, people are delusional.
So that, I don't get
a lot of value out of.
Lying or mean hate.
If somebody, haters that
pick on women and use sexual,
that, you're not gonna,
there's no engagement there.
People that are like,
"Gary, you're a charlatan.
"You're full of shit,
what have you ever done?"
I'm comfortable jumping in.
Be like, "Hey, I
understand you may not like
"the Instagram videos where I might come
"across too aggressive.
"But on that point of
what have I ever done?
I do think there should be a discussion
of I've built two massive business.
And to that point, that
might be a framework
to a conversation.
If their reply to you is
like, "Fuck you bitch."
Then I'm like, "Okay
this needs to move on."
If they're like, "Okay, that makes sense,
"I didn't realize that."
Then I'll come back and be
like, "Hey what about you?
"What do you do?"
I'm very capable of
dealing with negativity
because I come at it from
compassion and empathy.
They don't know me.
- [Heather] Right.
- Everybody in this room doesn't know me.
And I know these three
hang out with me a lot
and have a lot of access to me.
They don't fully know me.
Who knows you?
So when people are casting judgment,
this is why I don't take
compliments high either.
- That's hard, that is really,
you have to train yourself to do that.
- Well this is why, I look
at, there's a couple things
that people really struggle with.
If you're attractive as a guy or a gal,
inevitably you're in
trouble because you grew up
in a life where people
you you were attractive,
and you took that in.
If you had high success in school,
if you had high success in sport.
By not being an attractive
scholar or athlete,
I had none of those things.
And so what actually gave me reinforcement
was the end market.
Nobody complimented except the results
of my little businesses.
So I became market driven,
not people's opinions driven.
My friends--
- [Heather] Wow.
- Got it?
- [Heather] Yeah.
- That's what I've self-analyzed.
That's what I'm looking
for everybody else to do.
Forget about individual
opinions, what's the score say?
I always tell people,
"Do the people that
know you best like you?"
See, my thing is, there's
so many people out there
that are admired.
But if you look carefully,
their inner circle's garbage.
- [Heather] That's sad.
- Well, that's a lot of people
that people think are awesome.
Like a lot of people
that get exposed later
in the news, like bad shit.
Me Too, fraud, go to jail.
If you look carefully, you can be like,
"Why don't they have an inner circle?
"Why aren't there people
there for a long time?"
- [Heather] That's creepy.
- Like, I'm like, "Why do I
have people around me forever?"
It's not super complicated.
People get confused.
And then they'll reverse.
So, to me, I'd rather the people
that know me the best admire me the most.
And the people that don't know me at all
and are insecure and upset with
themselves hate me the most.
- [Heather] Absolutely.
- That's the game.
- [Heather] Done.
- Fear is the real, you
need to challenge yourself,
in my opinion, to play that exact,
you are not naturally that person.
Just like I'm not naturally work out well,
it's really fun to think,
I don't do radical candor well
'cause I hate micro
negativity, which has led
to all my vulnerabilities.
That's what I'm working on.
You need to fucking go all in
on everything that is judgment.
- [Heather] I love that.
- That's the game for you.
- [Heather] All right I'm in.
- Final point.
You get the floor for the
last 30 to 60 seconds.
- Fear is a liar and
confidence is the one thing
that can change everything for anyone.
And it's a choice.
It's not something you're born with.
- [Gary] It's practice.
- It is a practice.
Right.
It's a discipline and
it's decision everyday
when you wake up.
But, it's the game changer.
- I'm gonna add, and I apologize,
I said you get the last word
but I'm a fucking maniac.
I'm completely flawed.
It just made me think of something.
Judge the judger.
Couple of new big
executives have come Vayner
and they're like, "Wow, this
place is fucking amazing."
And I'm like, "Why?"
And both said the same thing.
They said, after six months, they're like,
"You don't just blindly take content
and context from people."
"You actually 360 it."
And I'm like, "What do you mean?"
They're like, "Well, a couple weeks ago,
"I told you Sally Magoo sucked
"and you came back a week later and said,
"you have a wrong perspective
'cause you only took it
"from one person's point of view.
"And you were right,
after I did the homework."
Judge the judger my friends.
If somebody says you're ugly,
you have to decide who that person is.
Including your mom.
Including your dad.
- Most importantly those people.
Because those people are coming
from their own challenging places.
- [Gary] Judge the judger.
- You're so right.
- People get feedback and
they're like, "I'm stupid."
I'm like, "Because Ricky
Magoo said you're stupid?"
Judge the judger.
That's the easiest way
to get into a fear based.
Here's my framework.
I don't let anybody else's
opinion override my own.
Judge the judger.
And when I lose, because
there is no judger,
it's just the market.
My book didn't sell, my
sports card didn't sell,
my business did bad, we got fired.
I accept it.
I own it.
When the market says you lost.
You have to own it.
It's like sports.
Either you lost or you won.
And when you lose you have to accept it.
But anything that's a subjective judgment,
judge the judger.
That's how you get a
relationship with fear.
- [Heather] So good.
- Awesome.
Thanks for being on.
- [Heather] Thank you!
- Bye bye!